the debates are important because this
is the hardest problem that we've ever
faced so did you have a position on
carbon credits coming into the day yeah
no the position is no there must be
something important in carbon Market
otherwise people have given up long time
ago today the carbon markets have no
Supply no demand no transparency no
regulation other than that they're
perfect different points of view can add
to the collective wisdom we'll work
better if we work together how do we
generate those connections that together
move us forward
now carbon credits are being used as a
big tool to neutralize otherwise growing
emissions are they working there are
three really big unimportant climate
outcomes that the carbon Market could
help with reduction protection and
removal our forests piglands and oceans
are more than the carbon that they store
the concern that I've got about Net Zero
and you're probably going to discreet
about this right it might be taking away
some of the sense of urgency complex
situations need both and thinking
instead of either or they require us to
hold competing values together rather
than make straightforward choices we
call these dilemmas I'm Lindsay Levin
co-founder of Ted countdown and this is
why we launched our dilemma series to
look at some of the thorniest issues in
the climate space and see how through
deep listening and collaboration we find
Pathways forward one of the most
powerful telescopes in the world had an
Innovative design when it was built
including the decision to build two
virtually identical telescopes only 60
meters apart the ability to view that
object from two different points of view
only 60 meters apart on a small planet
makes all the difference in the amount
of information that can be used to
enhance our understanding and the same
thing is true when we try to reason
together in a group if there are
different points of view then the
different life experiences of everyone
in the group can add to the collective
wisdom and make the group far smarter
than the smartest individual in that
group
thank you